really this topic is called other
applications of area and volume okay um
the kinds of things is going to include
our lots of shapes that have lots of bad
parts okay so when we look at surface
area and bone you unless you like these
and a half okay where we go subsetting
volume obviously where we're going to
begin for those kinds of shapes is the
area of a circle okay now you know what
the area of a circle is we might just
quickly review it though just so you
remember why it is what it is and
important parts of how you use it okay
so to start with okay there are two
formulas to do with circles one for
circumference and one foot area and
they're very alike formula for
circumference you've got you've got two
choices don't you you can write your
apply D which by the way that's the
definition of pi that's where the number
comes from it's the ratio between the
circumference and the diameter namely
the circumference is exactly that times
longer than the diameter okay people
muffle moment you get the idea okay of
course is the alternative way of writing
the circumference namely because of
course the diameter is just too up okay
so so far so good the area form of
course is very very close how is it
different PI Square okay so you may
remember in the genius school but this
is a a constant source of confusion for
students because of like they even use
the same numbers okay
what's the easiest way to remember which
ones which any takers
howdy and one you knew the PI R squared
is the area and not the other way around
okay because it's where like think me to
come think of them the units you're
going to use to describe the
circumference or describe the area okay
so for instance if I'm if I draw a
circle
okay if we measured this all around and
we use a string or something like that
we'd say the circumference is you know
some number say what would unit which
you used to describe this particular
size circle probably centimeters I think
meters is probably too big like this
would be maybe less than a meter or just
a meet-up synonymy this sounds like a
good choice okay so being that the units
for this iron centimeters as a parallel
the units for your area if I'm going on
the same circle would be centimeters
square and you can see right these match
up okay the number of dimensions here
centimeters by centimeters matches the
number of units of of not units the
number of lengths that you have here
radius and the greatest again as opposed
to just the ones so I want to show you a
quick proof for this there's a couple of
Handy proofs for this but you should
know where they come from it doesn't
just come from thin air okay so I've got
a circle let me hear yourself up and the
other circle doesn't have to be
beautiful I know you didn't bring your
equipment with you what you've got under
circle there all the proofs for the area
of a circle or any kind of spherical T
they all determine all unlike cutting up
into a bunch of different shapes and you
can do this a couple of different ways
one way is cutting up like a pizza and
then you get all these pizza slices you
can line them up the way that I like
doing it is like this draw in your
circle some concentric circles for as
many
that's okay
so draw that up now what have we got
here okay I have a series of rings that
they're all round at the moment so
that's not going to help me but I can
take those those rings and I can stretch
them out right so for instance if I take
like a sort of cross section like this
right if I cut all of the Ruiz here
right if you imagine in kind of like um
like a coiled up string I can then
unfurling I could straighten them out
right I'm gonna put them all into F I'm
gonna start from the one in the middle
okay this is gonna be equal to and if I
unferth it I'll get a little section or
a ring like that okay the next one here
this it's going to be once I unfurl it
it's gonna be a bit longer isn't it
right but it'll be the same width like
this okay now if I keep going all the
way down to the end and I put them all
next to each other and kind of like a
stack right I'm gonna get this kind of
shape it's gonna keep going and
eventually I'm going to get to the last
ring the one on the outside this one
okay now quickly tell me it's on the
board right how long is that last ring
we're not Unferth
how long is it going to be it's it's
gonna be all the way around like it's
the circumference isn't it it's the
outside yeah
so therefore when I've drawn all of
these little strips up and you should as
well and I line them all up I could do
more but I'm just going to stop there
for the sake of time okay this one along
the end this longest one okay it's going
to be from here to here to PI ah it's
the circumference unfurled okay now you
can see if I could draw my rings you
really really feel okay and I put them
all up next to each other you wouldn't
see like a bar graph type shape you just
can try
wouldn't you right and there'd be all
these little little thin lines in here
this one still will be 2 PI R tall but
what this measurement be where does that
come from it comes from my original cut
doesn't it
right it comes from young right I
thought and then all of these kind of
stand up and that distance is of course
the radius so you've got ah now this is
just a triangle and I know what it's
faces and I know what its height is it's
area is gonna be base times height / -
right choose cancel and that leaves you
with the familiar result okay like I
said that's not the only way to slice it
up the alternative is to do it like this
and instead of oh that's a bad cut
instead of creating a triangle if you
take all of these pizza slices and you
lay them in - and you'll get a rectangle
and you'll get much the same result okay